rénovation pour Ségolène
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane Guillon
bonsoir Stéphane
[Applaudissements]
et voilà politique le président est de
plus en plus nerveux tigres incessants
et grimaces note libération un
comportement qui est frais au salon de
l'agriculture il a même fallu museler
les vaches
à son contact certaines esquisser un
mouvement de recul on les comprend dans
une ferme ce type de tremblement
entraîne la battage du troupeau
les instituts de sondage inquiets si
Sarkozy continue à perdre 5 points par
semaine pour la première fois fin mars
un président sera sous la barre des 0
opinions positives
la fonction présidentielle de plus en
plus désacralisée c'est vrai regardez
cette photo une attitude que n'aurait
jamais eu Jacques Chirac ma télé fesses
de Bernadette
en même temps
question de survie presque
pour être élu à la tête du PS soyons
prêts à toutes les bassesses cette
semaine c'est Go s'affiche avec Georges
Frêche l'homme qui trouve qu'il y a trop
de noirs en équipe de France bientôt
Ségo pourrait s'afficher avec Pascal
Sevran l'homme qui voulait leur couper
la
innovation pour Ségolène
[Applaudissements]
voilà public de droite
immigration un jeune athlète kenyan se
suicide ça demande d'asile avait été
refusé l'immigration choisie c'est
uniquement pour les athlètes de haut
niveau il fallait courir plus vite
dans une période où les drames se
succèdent ne perdons pas le sens de
l'humour Rachida Dati à Brice Hortefeux
je t'ai vu en tenue traditionnelle du
Gabon Satan ainsi
international étonnant défilé en Inde un
suppositoire de Guy Carlier juché sur un
chat
social grève des remontées mécaniques à
Courchevel après Neuilly-sur-Seine c'est
le deuxième ghetto de riche qui
s'embrasse en 15 jours
manifestation de coiffeur contre une
proposition du rapport Attali qui les
oblige à tituler à ma brevet une mesure
qui frapperait lourdement le coiffeur de
Stéphane Bern
à Paris La Poste lance les boîtes aux
lettres du soir alors le soir pour la
poste c'est entre 16h et 20h après ils
vont se coucher ils sont crevés
faits divers un élève jugé pour avoir
poignardé son professeur oui alors on
peut les noter mais pas encore les
poignardées pour l'instant les enfants
ne vous énervez pas ça peut changer
génétique tous les individus aux yeux
bleus d'origine européenne partagent un
même en 7 putin je suis de la même
famille que Loana
dernière minute Cécilia convoqué dans
l'affaire du SMS alors une piste pour
les enquêteurs si le casse-toi pauvre
con était la réponse de Cécilia a si tu
reviens j'annule tout
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu